you can also I was on this thing called
JK news and you could see it on YouTube
and look I'll be straight up with you
these people in there are Asian and
Latino and by Latino I mean pretty much
Mexican and man I was nervous when I got
in there and I was nervous I guess you
know I was nervous because you know
honestly I thought that you know I guess
part of me you know you going to place
him I thought that these people were
better than me or that they were
thinking that they were better than me
and and they weren't they weren't it was
just as we were fear in my head you know
so I you know I got into this weird it
was early it was kind of early in the
morning for me I had a late night of
doing shows and next thing you know I'm
there and and and uh and I'm you know I
got in there and it's like a half hour
till we start and they're eating
Asian food early in the morning and some
people could say oh you think you're
being racist I'm not being racist I love
Asians dude give me an Asian right now
give me an Asian dude I'll [ __ ] put
him in my shirt I'll hug him I'll hold
them I'll start a family bruh
I'll put a cinnamon on them and start a
family of cinnamon Asians never seen
never seen by anyone rare very rare them
CAS and and but I'm not not gonna talk
about him not gonna say the word Asian
because I it's restraint enough just
describe somebody to you and be vague no
elsewhere please if you thinking like
that but dude I was in there and I felt
inferior a little bit and so I was kind
of scared and I was on my phone and like
you know looking up like man [ __ ] on my
phone like looking up like sports even
though it's 10:30 a.m. there's like no
sports going on someone ESPN app it's
like looking up cricket scores and like
uh you know soccer Liverpool is
Liverpool in every soccer game because
every time I look on it it's just that's
all it is
Liverpool Liverpool Liverpool so that's
kind of how that broke down and I'm
sitting there and and then we got
started and it was fun man it was like
you know I've never you know what I
realized I've never hung out with Asian
people that much and these people were
they had Vietnamese they had
um Japanese you know they had
straight-up [ __ ] Dragonball Z was in
that [ __ ] it got hell Asian I
didn't know what was going on and man
they were more there show the the
Japanese and Mexican hosts hosts that
were in there were more real than any of
the shows I've been on I think a lot of
like in that there's this thing in like
um with some of the white hosts that
I've been around the white culture where
we are afraid to speak our minds and
those people are fearless and dude I
didn't I guess I thought I would go and
it would be less you know I guess I
thought that they would be more fearful
for some reason but it was inspiring I
got in there and they were fearless
they shared what they really felt and
they and they weren't and you could tell
where they came from they weren't from a
bad place but they were just very real
and it was refreshing and some thankful
to them that stuff's called JK news and
we did about 15 clips and it's all out
there on youtube if you want to check it
out thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz it's alarming